yourself from her but you still love her
yeah are you still gonna stay yeah
okay
because at that moment i'd understand
that there's more to it than just my
feelings or at that current moment in
time because if you're telling me at
that moment i'm not feeling it cool what
happens in two months time no but you
can feel the relationship deterring like
you just
you can feel yourself you know what i'm
about to do something unfaithful
yeah if i'm about to oh gosh like god
forbid but if i'm about to do something
unfaithful which
yeah i'd i'd i'd leave like i would
never want to do that to someone john i
mean
okay so yeah if i leave but here's as a
man of principle
if i leave i'm not coming back
because
my my mindset is
what
took it so far that i couldn't have
worked hard to make sure we didn't break
up but what would you enter something
prematurely
wait
all right if i
explain that how would i enter something
prematurely
you met a girl now yeah
and
maybe you're younger
yeah okay maybe it's because you're
younger
you're now dating her and whatnot what
not and you're like oh
i would have known within the first
i'd say 15 seconds whether
i want to take her seriously or i did
this is a casual thing
just just to let you know
like
that's whether i want to i i would then
find out through character that maybe
she's not a serious candidate
maybe she is but within the first 15
seconds i know
so there's no premature thing maybe i
amanda might be lying saying oh like
there is like i i couldn't tell i don't
know what it is they're lying they knew
exactly what it was from the jump they
know within 15 seconds the first
conversation whether they are feeling
you or whether this is a
yeah i'm just trying to smash and move
on so can i just
sure um
i feel like from this conversation and
previous conversation it feels like even
paul said that we are applying for role
as a wife
even though there can be women of high
value
even they
have to apply for the role so everything
revolves around the man and
without the man
you can't do nothing because it's im
impossible to be independent
but um
it just feels like
if you're if you're a certain type of
way if you're modern whatever you want
to call it
then
you're not going to find a
i don't even want to say high value
because it's not necessarily just about
money because my
the definition of high value that i've
got is about money but for me obviously
the high value is something completely
different but then you guys would say
that's beta no
i would say
in general the guys that women are
attracted to
don't prefer modern women it's not to
say that they never date or marry them
but
most men prefer traditional women
you're just you're saying that it's
something basically it won't really end
well with a modern woman no and look at
we're all most girls in the west are
modern to some extent
if i'm i'm 25 if i'm going up against
like a 22 year old girl from eastern
europe she's probably going to win
but at least if we know the game you can
play it better
but
like like
like it's just western world we're just
we have too many options
like we have so many different options
you're you're right you have options at
this age
and that's the important thing that
feminism doesn't really
showcase to you like it doesn't showcase
to you the consequences of your actions
at this age at this age you have so many
options you're a pretty girl
yeah you're gonna have pick it a bunch
but you were you may not realize that
the pick of the bunch that you're
looking at the guys at the higher end of
that pick that you have
just want to smash and dock they're not
looking for anything long term and you
might be excusing the guys that maybe
are on your level and you'll go
um i can get better than you because
you're probably getting with guys that
are a lot better let me let me read them
yeah
who do you guys remember the thing they
saw oh goodness i do want to say
something before you read that long long
list
email i don't know if you said this ish
but um something that i've learned from
just being around pearl
being on the podcast watching the videos
is because you were saying um what if
you feel like
um
you're not what if you're not feeling it
men don't think feel they think
logically women are like oh i'm not
feeling it feel feel feel that's how
women think so when you were saying that
i said uh that's that's understanding
because that's how women think but men
are they're not thinking like oh i'm not
feeling it they're either going to
be with the girl or not that's just it's
like their brains are so simple
and we're living in such a pc world at
this moment in time that
let's say there's an action that i've
seen you do yeah
and i don't like it
i'm not gonna tell you i'm just gonna
move on quietly
or i'm just gonna allow all whatever
we're doing to finish and then move on
because i understand that in the world
we live in today
me trying to tell you about yourself
will come across as ah i'm trying to
control you or i'm trying to
you know i mean i think it and it's it's
one of those things where
it's not so that i'm trying to control
you i'm just laying down stipulations to
say look this is what i would want
in my partner in order to have a
relationship if you don't want to do
that then call i understand you we can
go our separate ways no harm done
but it's i feel like a lot of
no not a lot i feel like
the younger lot
yeah
being straightforward
is
rare
so then as paul said you shouldn't be
going for the younger lord go for the
older lot no but that's what i'm saying
like
some people may not feel comfortable
going for the old a lot yeah but that's
because that's the thing like girls want
everything
so it's like we want a guy that's driven
or successful we gotta go that's our age
we want a guy that's taller than us we
want it like we have all these things we
want and the thing is like you can't
have everything you have to think about
the trade-offs so if you want a guy
that's ready to get married quicker find
a guy that's older you'll have more of
your youth to leverage you know what i
will say before i leave i feel like
being here the other day and today i
think i said it before it is all a
learning lesson for me i take everything
with like
i don't see it as a oh because i used to
feel like stuff like this is me being
attacked and whatnot but like no i
honestly really appreciate being able to
come and actually listen and understand
because it's
kind of answering some questions yeah
get your gears turned answering the
crazy
but yeah no thank you yeah once you
unsee it you will never be able to once
you see it you will never be able to see
it
you can't
like i i used to like
hear this stuff and it doesn't sound
nice because you're like ah it is yeah
but it's just like at least yeah but at
least like when you know okay like if i
lose 20 pounds i gain a point like [ __ ]
then i'm gonna work to do that like it's
like if you know the game at least you
can compete
and like some [ __ ] you can undo sure but
it's like at least if you know the game
you can compete better and at least if
you're like if you listen to the guys
you can get the guy like then we can at
least go for the guys we want rather
than settle for the guys that come to us
yeah
like true yeah i don't even settle for
the guys that come to me anyway i don't
wanna
i don't wanna well you should don't want
them